hey wait
wait i gotta do this to him
hey man are you good are you all right
mom stay with me is that god hey what's
going on everybody for first week feast
i'm shawn evans and welcome back to
another exciting episode of truth or dab
the hot one special where we give our
guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last app
and today we welcome internet bffs and
fellow short kings cody co noel miller
tmg the latest single is sophia shout
out tiny meat gang wherever you get your
podcasts
and check out the kodiko and noel miller
youtube channels respectively but first
a good old-fashioned game
truth or dab noel cody welcome to the
show
this feels like a fever dream and i'm
sure it's gonna feel more like a fever
dream after i eat one of these
can i just say this is an honor yeah and
a privilege but also i'm
[ __ ] my pants already out of nerves
i'm so nervous for this
i poured out the first one the reaper
and i was coughing
as it was hitting my nose so you know i
can only imagine what it's going to be
like when it goes in my system
so cody we're gonna start with you to
kick things off okay
good yeah good [ __ ] start with me sure
okay so you guys are perhaps best known
for your work on the wildly popular
that's cringe series where you do an
excellent job of towing the line between
the cruel
and the comedy but i have to imagine
that with a format like that
things go sliding off the rails every
once in a while
besides that face-to-face confrontation
with jake paul on the set of jeff's
barber shop
which celebrity which channel had the
biggest
most volatile reaction to being goofed
on on the internet
i would def i would definitely say the
jake paul one is is
is probably the most the craziest
physical confrontation i've ever had
that's like one of the only
confrontations i've ever had physically
i'm not a very confrontational person
you know i'm like you said
fellow short king yep so uh you know i'm
like uh
you know i like to use my twitter
fingers you know i'm a he's a [ __ ] is
what he's saying i'm a [ __ ] it's
basically what i'm saying
um so basically i heard through
someone that i know who knows someone
that laylee ponz's manager
really really hates me like really hates
me and said that next time he sees me
he's going to beat me up or something
like that or or
i'm going to catch hands or something
like that and uh
and i think that's also the reason why
justin bieber blocked me
on instagram because he is friends with
him close friends
and i think they both really don't like
me which kind of sucks because i'm a big
justin bieber fan
and i'm i like lele pawns too you know
she's got some bangers
noel i imagine that sometimes these
people's fans will return
fire and shoot back at you guys when you
think of
all the niche interest groups that you
guys have annoyed on the internet over
the years
whose fans would you say are the most
savage and want the most internet smoke
like what is the hornet's nest that
you've poked that's a great question
basically i think the bts fandom is a
one big hostage pyramid scheme you know
you make one bad comment and then they
get on you and then it just becomes
deeper and deeper
and you can't not be a fan so with that
being said uh jimin happy birthday
and i love bts
all right are you guys ready to move on
here to the next
round yeah yeah so in 2019 tiny meat
gang won the shorty award for best
podcast
also winning awards that night were the
try guys
vlogger ryland adams ninja and ariana
grande
noelle can you rank those fellow winners
from most deserving of their award to
least deserving of their award
oh easy i love this i love this
off rip i'm gonna give the try guys most
deserving those guys hustle
everyone parodies what they do but you
cannot deny the work ethic of those guys
i'm gonna give number two to ryland just
because he's a vlogger and you have to
have so much not give a [ __ ] to be a
vlogger
i'm gonna go ariana above ninja so ninja
i'm ranking you number four because
um you don't need it man you're good
number oh also number one is bts they
deserve it though
yeah but above everyone else bts for
sure yeah
is the 1a just want to make that very
clear bts is number one in our hearts
and our minds yeah
and then cody you know you guys as a
collective i think that you've been
nominated or won in
every single internet award show which
of those internet award shows or honors
ceremonies do you think deserves the
least respect like which is the goofiest
out of the streamies the shorties and
the webbies
hey eat that wing bro
get it get it in there down the hatchet
oh man you know i don't want to hurt my
chances of winning future awards i gotta
fill these shelves with something
yeah yeah and they're like so nice to
you when you get there and stuff i felt
bad writing the question but did need to
be asked
yeah but out of respect because they've
invited us
to to give speeches there to present
awards and because i don't want to
affect my chances of
stalking my shelves with future awards
because who knows
this could you know trickle up to the
grammys or something and then
the grammys won't give tiny meat gang
their rightful award because we talk
[ __ ] on award shows so i'm going to go
ahead and i'm going to eat the first
wing
how much do i see just whenever you feel
comfortable doing cody
don't put too much pressure on yourself
but the entire internet is watching
[Music]
oh yeah that's nothing you wore a
sweater to this you dummy
it's already starting oh my god
i so badly want to put reverb on my mic
and just start [ __ ] with you
yeah shame that one's funny i gotta do
this to him
i have to do this too hey man are you
good
are you all right mom
stay with me is that god
[Music]
i'm sorry i made fun of girl defined
this is jimin
this is no joke man all right cody
good thing is we're running to the
finish line here we're already halfway
done with the show
and you guys are obviously entertainment
success stories but i know that it was a
long crazy road to get there
noelle i understand that it was hard for
you to hop on board with the music
because music for you was a chapter that
you wanted to leave in your past
prior to your days of doing tiny meat
gang
when you were a backpack rapper can you
give us
maybe two three bars that you remember
delivering from that era
yeah what's actually really cool is
people i grew up with
they remember that stuff some some of
them remember whole songs which i
um find crazy because i genuinely can't
remember a lot of what i wrote
i can remember it was like a battle
between like a couple of my friends
versus a couple of random dudes there
and uh i remember this one guy there
he was wearing like an iced tea type
chain like it was like a big ass
bike chain around his neck uh cody you
good you following here
you got the story right are you even
speaking english yeah ah
recant to me what i just said am i
speaking english yeah
okay so he's talking about shooting
everybody at the party
uh and i remember i i had walked in and
i called my friends go you gotta you
gotta
you gotta do him so i grabbed the
microphone and i
i forget the first two bars but i
remember looking straight at him and
this dude could have leveled me like
clean he was a big dude and i said hey
bro
quit making me laugh quit talking about
them guns that you don't even have
and i remember the whole uh everyone
[ __ ] the bed
and then after after the thing had died
down i walked up to him i said hey man
you know i saw jokes and i extended my
hand and he he just looked
away and shook his head and i actually
felt bad so
grown man got done by 16 year old
that's funny dude cody you've described
your first ever
stand-up performance as being so bad
and saying that you performed in a room
of four people
with your brain on fire right now can
you give us one
setup and one punch line from that set
you you know which one you got to do
what are you doing i can't think of
anything right now so what are you what
are you doing for the summer
oh yeah this was actually probably one
of the good jokes
i said uh i've been thinking about
growing my dick out for the summer
and that was the whole joke
[Music]
dude i'm dizzy i'm like literally this
feels like i've been drinking or
something
alright here we are in the last round
so your music video for broke [ __ ]
features this really smart on the nose
wink at corporate overreach in the age
of digital entertainment with this
full-blown self-effacing seat geek
interlude
noel at the risk of costing you guys a
future bag
what is the dumbest note the dumbest
suggestion
that you've ever gotten from a brand
sponsor
and with that cheers brother oh he's
going in he's joining that's a good
friend right there he's joining in
thank you i appreciate it i've just been
suffering here alone
for the past 10 minutes right now oh
what the [ __ ]
oh it's just the beginning strapping i
actually need the milk already
strap in all right all right all right
all right
all right do you want me to give my
feelings or do you want cody to go first
and i can talk after
give us your feelings because i just
have one more i just have one more
question for cody and then
and then and then it's a wrap so so
please please whatever's on your mind
let me know
i feel like my tongue is going through
like a
like a meat grinder or something like
it's just like pain
oh oh my [ __ ] what is this man
oh brother this is good right this is
the feeling men get in their mouth when
they have to tell the truth
to their significant other oh it hurts
this bad all right cody go ahead
[ __ ] this cody get you out of here on
this i know that you're a good friend
but you got to tell us
what's one thing that internet haters
get right
about noelle
nothing can hurt my feelings go for it
oh man you're going for the throat on
that one
i'll just say it that's like a last
ditch like if they haven't eaten any
wings by this point
this will get one of those fuckably to
wing um
i already paid respect to the wonderful
internet award shows that we love so
much and aren't corny at all
and i think i'm i'm also going to pay
respect
to my co-host oh quit being a [ __ ] just
say it
you wish i would say it i'm going to eat
this wing instead oh you're a psycho
[Music]
i can tell you for you what is it oh
this is so messed up
i have a bad habit of rambling on the
podcast sometimes i
steamroll cody
i'm just that's i'm just built that way
and i'm sorry
oh my god this is like pure pain yeah
that's definitely the worst thing that's
the thing that they get right for sure
that's the worst thing i mean that's not
the worst thing this is something that
comes to mind
all right just say it what if you got a
different idea i don't care
uh i don't i don't actually have it
cody's just he's just a good friend he's
just gonna fall
he's just gonna fall on that grenade for
you no i was hoping he'd say something
so i could pretend to be really offended
all right go ahead john i'm sorry
this one's good all right guys we have
reached the finish line
mercifully thankfully we have reached
the finish line
is there anything that you guys want to
get off your chest before we roll
curtains and get you guys to an ice bath
um honestly man thank you for bringing
us on dude it's an honor
we [ __ ] love you and we love your
show so much and it's
great to hear you interview someone in
person and it's even better that it's us
sean do you do this so people cry while
they thank you for bringing them on the
show
it forever bonds us you know this
experience
jesus christ we're enemies for life now
this is what
see you at the shorties see you at the
shorty awards [ __ ] see you man
oh my god dude this is what they need to
use for interrogations
job guys great job how you feeling
not like i'm dying i really feel it in
my head
like i'm like i'm dizzy make sure that
you
wash your hands thoroughly finish that
chocolate milk cody and you'll be good
to go
you'll be good to go oh my god ah don't
gotta tell me twice
oh my god hey man are you good
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in with a very
exciting announcement
hot ones truth or dab the game is
finally here baby
what's in the box what's in the box
what's in the box
well the kit comes complete with 250
question cards
and then here's how the game works you
just go around the table
you take turns being the host being the
players
and when you're a player you get asked a
question you have a choice
just like in the show answer it honestly
or suffer the wrath of the last dab and
take a look at this
there's even a mini bottle of the last
dab included i suggest you have napkins
on hand
you have to have some milk on hand and
of course be careful be very careful
around the eyes hot ones truth or dab
the play at home game is available at
shop.firstwe fees.com
heatness.com and amazon play at your own
risk
wings not included
[Music]
you